the taliban
are apparently taking care of those dogs
that were left by the united states upon
the evacuation from afghanistan so you
remember this was the united states left
well over 100 americans probably many
more than that
the united states left afghan allies i
have actually spoken to friends of mine
who are uh
either in the armed forces or
have been in the armed forces who have
have been getting calls from
americans who are stuck or from friends
of americans who are stuck in
afghanistan so this is a real problem
of
christians who are stuck chaplains and
priests of lots of people who are there
so this is a real problem but then what
everyone freaked out about was that they
left the dogs the serviced poor dogs are
in afghanistan so okay it's not a good
look
the taliban though these pr geniuses
they are their pr geniuses
are taking to the western press to let
you know don't worry we're taking care
of your dogs
the americans left the dogs to get out
from their specific places but
our teams and our officials called in
charge of those dogs and
today
they came to import and they are trying
to
collect the dogs and they are trying to
facility for them and uh what they need
to give them is their is they alive and
how many are they um particularly i
cannot give you a specific number but
they are alive and
from the beginning when we come to the
front line of front door of the airport
we were in
we were in touch with the
in charge of the dog and they are
working and they are
feeding the dogs and i think there's no
problem and there's no pro this is good
news right this is i i hate that i have
the
the taliban have been very good about
this from the beginning they've been
very good
at
their propaganda
and
the west has not been so they held that
press conference when they took over the
presidential palace in kabul
joe biden wouldn't hold a press
conference
so you're seeing here you say oh my gosh
the taliban is giving greater
transparency to the press and the people
than the white house is
then the taliban is asked about freedom
of speech they say you know
you and the west like to talk about
freedom of speech what about facebook
facebook's censoring lots and lots of
your people including the newly elected
president for goodness sakes on january
7th
oh yeah you can't really talk about that
and now the west we can't even take care
of our own service dogs don't worry the
taliban's taking care of it
thank you so much for watching that clip
i'm glad that you liked it what i would
love for you to do right now please
humor me i i really appreciate it take
out your phone i'll take out my phone
go to your podcast app
click that's apple podcast spotify
stitch or whatever type in the michael
knowles show now it might not come up
right away because sometimes big tech
likes to suppress i'm not making any
accusations but they don't always love
the show you find the michael knowles
show you click subscribe
wonderful thank you
you leave a five star review if you want
okay thank you that's really nice and
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you